and then I said that was Ned's wife oh
hi didn't see you there welcome to my
home Oh bartender the usual please and
what would that be
only the most iconic drink across
America which states all of them welcome
to my blog when the try guys first
started doing vlogs I literally said
dang this is a [ __ ] stupid idea
but I've warmed up to it normally you
see things from like this on a cellphone
but I prefer things film like this on a
tripod so [ __ ] this phone someone check
if that's okay the other try guys are
gonna be guest starring in this video as
we go through all 50 states it somebody
say alcohol yes wait so we're gonna be
drinking 50 drinks not all 50 drinks now
four of the states have the strictest
drinking laws and they will be giving us
water because we like to drink
responsibly during our last responsibly
we have an amazing bartender say payback
over here today you start us off with
Alabama and you got it ready for this
for you ready is that a spit bucket yes
perfect
just get a big yellow hammer
I kind of drink of the University of
Alabama football oh I could drink 20 of
these without even blinking this is baby
juice this is you okay so next part well
Bailey's in Cologne you know is gonna be
tasty uh-huh
so they called the duck part because the
parents the sounds you make after you
drink it oh really I think we just did
oh yeah it's like Donald Duck white
noise I make after I come up next
Arizona tequila sunrise oh baby oh baby
give me some Sun blocking an umbrella
oh man are you a tequila girl wouldn't
want to take my pants off I feel like
this is a monitoring a mom and vacation
family I want to get like saucy today I
will say the raspberry adds a nice touch
did you do this
yeah turn that into a gift Internet so
this was a surprise mayor zona you know
some Arizona see this is an educational
video yeah it's like the old saying if
you're drinking and learning you're
probably next I can't drop the Arkansas
Razorbacks house here you want bumble
listen if I don't have a date by the end
of this Tay Tay's cute and that's not
the alcohol tax is pretty quick our
bartender why not that's like literally
what bartenders are for oh no I didn't
mean that kind of though what though
look that tastes like the bottom of a
coffee filter
that's like watered-down cold brew yes
with amaretto Arkansas is where Bill
Clinton's from oh this tastes like AB
so it's only fitting that we bring in
our first try guests did someone say red
you know I took a trip to Napa with my
wife drank a lot of Chardonnay they're
gonna give us a nice nice oaky cab did
you know that california produces the
most wine than any other state in the
United States you get a kidney in effect
I had a lot of sex in the UT I went
backwards upon I just feel classy are
already that really classes up the joint
because he's not like grossing me all
right you ready mm-hmm
Kelsey we heard Oakley on California
Jesus Christ
Colorado has the second most breweries
out of any state in the nation this beer
is delicious
it'll injury me most I mean grapefruit
literally says to control the pot beer
is kind of almost like its own beer yeah
sometimes I'll go out just for beer and
consider it dinner that's not healthy
hmm well next can't go wrong with wine
once again then they say wait
white wine when I went to Yale it was
some of the best times of my life I'm
not a big fan of sweeter one so meaning
I'm not like really into the Northeast
thing so to close this out tell us
something yellows that we can like can
yeah Bulldogs Bulldogs bad well well Eli
yeah that's the [ __ ] yes next Delaware
beer again oh that is mmm that is deep
that is IPA that is I - yeah yeah what's
this an artichoke
that's a pop what pops you know Florida
in the face there's one thing I can tell
about Florida it's we like to [ __ ]
get after it
yeah we do how to deal from Miami mess
we're from dirty dirty gross like
northern yeah yeah yeah I'm tempeh or
shrimp but as we like to call it
a lot of phone next ring yeah let's
[ __ ] Florida thumb yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass State Georgia Scarlett O'Hara
Oh named after the iconic character for
Gone with the Wind
hmm why is this so bitter this is sour
it's almost like drinking a Sour Patch
Kid I like it I'm gonna go ahead and
take this back to Georgia next next
Hawaii I gotta say the tropical drinks
are dangerous because you always
associated with the heat you want to
drink more and it doesn't taste like
alcohol
I want to dip in the Hawaiian beach you
know I want to see my wallet
did you go to Brooklyn almost me and
Milano Barack Obama just said oh he's
being like yo rock about in this for y
right yeah Wow that's the whole thing
Yugi oh I defend the back hi-de-ho wine
here's an amazing man according to a
2013 study the people of Idaho consumed
wine more than any other state in the
u.s. you know Idaho's great hiking don't
care next
did the Illinois or Illinois's Illinois
Jepsen's malort but let's bring in
someone who's lived in Chicago for a bit
of his life the one the only
it's me tell us about Lord it is a very
bitter it kind of tastes like the water
at the end of a garbage can
oh [ __ ] you can only get milord in
Chicago Wow so this is gonna be [ __ ] huh
oh it's bad
Oh Oh No why why why why what is that yo
its hominy sounds like 9 on the cup
sprig of every herb let me just put
something in the back of your [ __ ]
your mouth with a pencil face back with
a sharpie people don't take this drink
is fantastic it's Apple II no that's
good that's good what do you feel about
in the can huh
you've been to Indianapolis it's like a
mile long and no one's there there's
more in there Gary Indiana oh it's a
great emptiness it's not that Chicagoans
hate Indiana is this Indiana sucks in
general it's true all right Templeton
rye whistle I liked smokier tasting
whiskey's but this is uh this is
something I think my mom could drink I
could give this to a baby you would use
as a medicine for little kids when
they're coughing typically Templeton
give it to your sick children with polio
from the University of Kansas you can
tell that this is some [ __ ] that sugar
yes [ __ ] yeah if you're dreaming you're
having sex tonight
oh well mixed concoction for regrettable
decisions and almost surefire recipe for
disaster that's like you're by Harry
uncomfortable mint julep oh I have to
put you straight from the Derby oh my
goodness
this is a very state ace trying to [ __ ]
I'm calling it right now joke might be
trying to for the 120,000 of these are
consumed at the Kentucky's every year
for being drunk oh my god
can I say this is one of those drinks
that you have where you just go bless
her heart
it's a big hat drink it was invented in
the 1830s by an apothecary that's a guy
who does magic is it not I think this
isn't my favorite so far it leaves a
very fresh clean crisp aftertaste it's
not one of those drinks where you do it
you're like what doesn't taste clean and
crisp as an aftertaste dick mmm Maine
where kill people live and Jewish kids
go to summer camp
allons is called the champagne of Maine
this is chocolate milk I'm allergic to
coffee
I'm also severely lactose intolerant and
allergic to dairy this is hardly a
coffee both was just sick except I just
want to say like for the kids watching
you don't have to drink good point case
important I still drink a lot hey wait
[ __ ]
black-eyed Susan dude this is [ __ ]
good it's one of those wines that's oh
geez honey so you know Kentucky Derby's
like fancy hats hmm Preakness is like
flip-flops and ass flip-flop and ass
ya know yeah we don't [ __ ] horses how
did you connect that for I just said
next Massachusetts Massachusetts
my god is it - [ __ ] sort rusev how drunk
are you
that's it Kelsey it's the first of our
strict alcohol law states we're getting
water date laws bed any drink specials
including happy hour there are no happy
hour
Ryan Massachusetts I am NOT surprised it
was a huge pain in the ass during
college Marly your one friend with the
fake ID as a friend oh nothing I'm think
we should drink is underage but oh you
do a run up and get out of here
Michigan means why didn't I think Mead
was beer so Mead or honey wine maybe the
first alcoholic drink seaman's have ever
tasted
yeah that is so [ __ ] good it tastes
like wine and whiskey but without the
burn of whiskey sweet bubbly for a
second many people from Michigan now
that I'm thinking about it this is all
begin to something outside we're gonna
get to the next eight minutes a bootleg
oh but my ass that's delicious
it's like a gin mojito Fred even in
Minnesota wow really
what's there blonde people little Asians
there yeah
hi Asian Minnesotans Mississippi IPD IG
is M Mississippi punch whoo that is so
many flavors added a dank the southern
club drink well you need one of these to
be [ __ ] up but it's the Hennessy that
like tops it off smart you in the face
Mississippi was the last state to end
prohibition in 1966 Wow why were they so
on the wrong side of history next
Missouri's Bud Light we are officially
halfway through the nation how you
feelin I feel great okay I love that
it's commemorated by Bud Light the most
popular beer in the country not far by a
limit I feel like because we're halfway
we should commemorate with a little bit
of a chug you know
[Applause]
[Music]
America next Montana's the whiskey ditch
what'd you call me you know what
that's dangerous that takes the sting
right out of a whiskey
what's Montana known for beautiful
scenery you you really need to get out
more Kelsey you don't know where any of
the national parks are in the US you
know where is Yellowstone
where's Yosemite next kool-aid caddie we
have very hard time finding on a chronic
cocktail for Nebraska but if there's
kool-aid yeah then people will like it
yeah this is [ __ ] dope if Eugene can I
put on my jacket no no your nipples look
great sham campaign yeah you know what's
great about champagne everything Kelsey
why are you gonna share pain at your
wedding I'm not getting married
can I have champagne at your funeral
next New Hampshire another wine stage oh
yeah New Hampshire is the home of the
highest percentage of alcohol drinkers
across
[Music]
I'm going to New Hampshire max rejoices
Laird's Applejack well it was started by
Robert Laird who served under George
Washington in the Revolutionary War this
is a colonial drink New Jersey's just
got him like you know like extended New
York it's like you know it's we don't
have room for everything so we kind of
dump some of the [ __ ] in there how is it
okay okay wow that's really good almost
like a fire bomb without the cinnamon
spice I will say New Jersey smells like
farts when you enter in my Oh like to
kill a bit larger whoa Arizona's for
like young party people but New Mexico's
for like old party people
yeah ready to settle down but also get
wasted is it Breaking Bad in New Mexico
or is that Arizona they're the same
state I thought no I think the same
state it's breaking good hope next New
York City I met in New York
finally the Manhattan a drink much like
the city itself classy refined a little
overpriced considering how much real
estate you get yeah like I just look
like a classic [ __ ] hold on then okay
like don't I just look hotter no I will
say the first time I ever saw a man in
New York City or where was the second
time my apartment cherry bounce it seems
like watermelon
no but the cherries flavor is very
strong the state didn't esily come up
with a drink but it was quickly taken as
its own because many believe this
showcasing it North Carolina's
brightness we're just gonna pretend like
give you the price top for the videos
with me here the facts denial it's my
favorite stage mmm
North Dakota
beer North Dakota has the highest beer
consumption out of any state in the
country that would explain why people
are so fat they're just not that is not
right
Ohio the Buckeye martini hey what's a
Buckeye I don't know what the [ __ ] guy
is
I think it's an utter words piece of
chocolate pick this up chestnut Oh nut
tree nobody knocks harder than Kelsey
yeah they know next the second strict
alcohol stay Oh
the state did not repeal prohibition
until 1959 and restaurants were not able
to serve mixed drinks until the 1980
what okay so I was born the eighties
yeah what would I have drank then milk
from your mother's teats organ organ
what did you say Oregon organ what the
[ __ ] did you say dear I look at good
high alcohol content you are you too
you know this is one of those beers that
you can't chug you just have to sip on
it lately and act like a girl uh-huh
this is a beer what else is about all
you who cares next no organized like the
hipster culture like Portland you know
my underclothes maybe you should kiss it
to make it feel better
big kiss you're under rocks my god it's
the third strict alcohol the states when
it comes to access to alcohol because of
its Quaker roots I guess like if we had
to choose a beer jingling would be the
Pennsylvania beer right okay fun fact
Eugenia never heard of yang Ling and
looked up how to pronounce it cuz he
thought it was an Asian beer a what it
looks like it should be Asian next Rhode
Island the Rhode Island Red this is
named after a bright red chicken that is
[ __ ] good another one that tastes
like wow you know what I would have more
to say but Rhode Island is the smallest
state in America so sweet tea and birth
alright there's nothing wrong with sweet
tea or bourbon wow this is the back
porch drink yes I want to be sippin on
this while sitting in a rocking chair
talking to my grandchildren now sweetie
you never have
many early canola meal South Carolina
where I'm just like gone yeah okay CUDA
beer hey go South Dakota get your shine
on girl
the point is is the more north you go
the more colder you are the more you
have to drink to do stuff this now turns
the South baby where's the Jack Daniels
drop off the bottle or two of these
you're not tasting the whiskey at all
also Lynchburg a dry County what the
gift shop for Jack Daniels is in the
other County are you so the hearings I
don't know we're not I'm not swinging
the purse whiskey they own this they
need to use it nice drinks all right you
broke the quick Borisov favorite liquor
15 states including Tennessee I found
Esther no no no you can trade out of all
it's not yours
Haven frozen margarita we're always
surprised when they find out I'm from
Texas I don't know why I'm gonna say
crisis Russ you're [ __ ] wrestling I'm
Texan is fun wow that is good markers of
the most popular cocktail ordered in the
United States why yuria I like to kill
it but like I said they make my panties
come on Texas really know how to be
classy about [ __ ] really like don't need
a scream about house here they are we
just are naturally superior in so many
ways do you know what rhymes with Tex B
fourth and final but if you freely water
in restaurants bartenders must mix mix
drinks out of sight must be ordered with
food or at least and appetizers you
can't go to a bar and be like I'm an on
day I want to drink and grocery and
convenience stores may only sell beer
with a 3.2 percent alcohol by weight tax
the same goes for beer on what stuff
Hawaii tales of kegs are prohibited in
Utah cocktail I can't tell rock tales
are restricted to hold only one point
five ounces of primary liquor goodbye
they also the digital quarters where it
stopped it at a certain port it wouldn't
go furthest you can never have a hit
before he left so high
I'm not making out with you are you sure
your mom why oh yeah again yeah are you
okay yeah
putting next so let's move on to the
next like that are you guys okay I'm
sorry I didn't mean to make this video I
don't know if you guys are mad oh my god
are you getting emoji in the video it's
late and the sun's going down
Virginia Virginia oh [ __ ] Buchan shine
oh that tastes like [ __ ] you ready
I'm gonna take a little taste no ok
Virginia why is it so late it's rather
y'all got rushing the hard cider
the current cider broom is largely
centralized in fishing today is that one
at Washington Apple is Washington Apple
literally that's what it is in 16th
century colonial America well you know
what I agree I always want to apologize
to all the W starting stage now is
really far
let me art cider is like pretty easy
drink it's a nice like like seven of
these no not drink also I'm American
you're American we love each other you
know each other I feel like great about
being mean we might have different
politics but we all looking like that
all wet
virgin moonshine in your head what Oh
God again
the Appalachian three times bad
Appalachian Appalachian epilation yeah
oh well you [ __ ] drink the whole
thing [ __ ] Kelsey got there are you you
are you drunk yes
West Virginia Ellen five six seven eight
guys I got it I got it
that is a really strong moonshine we'd
say it's a with me the Bloody Mary one
of my favorite drinks can I take
something out Wisconsin
this is you'd think tomato soup early in
the morning isn't good but this is
exactly what you want my titties falling
out
it's Fame - it's not something live as
they do that's where they pull it wider
on there as a non-white person you know
why I understand all of that it's all
important but my thing is why why people
always making so many casseroles save
the state last date well Leslie it's the
last thing we're gonna be sad so why can
I just say we're ending on a note truly
speaking to my soul yeah any [ __ ] that
ever went to college I've had Franzia
can I cook can I admit something right
now
I've never had fancy oh my god I am
nervous wait we gotta we gotta play my
favorite game it's what is that this
looks like a placenta the same okay
this how this game works if you slap it
and it spins around and then however
many times it's been drowned you have to
chug for America I think for Wyoming you
gotta slap it it network so up now use
open it and drink it it's like a spout
go Wyoming are we all rolling yeah what
it what a journey we've had thank you so
much to America for enjoying your
Novation so until next time say the Troy
guys that try guys alumni say holy try
next
[Music]
this was a blog I did it Zack Ned was it
ok who is it good I don't think it was
good well I've never liked that